alors je viens mettre la clé hop le
contact je m'assure que le coupe-circuit
est bien en place donc là on est bon
c'est un cours de conduite un peu
particulier dans lequel ces deux élèves
s'apprêtent à s'embarquer depuis 2020
l'école au tout permis permet aux
Franciliens dès 16 ans de passer leur
permis bateau dans les Yvelines une
formation qui a le vent en poupe aux
commandes de l'établissement
matthewelden ancien pompier et sauveteur
en mer une fois que la formation
théorique est faite il y a un examen
théorique à passer et une fois qu'on a
validé l'examen théorique donc on fait
la formation pratique et on a les
différents objectifs à valider place à
la pratique pour nos élèves du jour
c'est parti pour 3h30 de navigation et
de manœuvre au rythme de la scène
il y a pas de problème
alors du coup on va pouvoir se mettre en
marche avant
voilà la gâchette on pousse vers l'avant
nickel hop on va pouvoir trouver un
régime moteur 1300 tours là on est
actuellement à 700 tours minute première
épreuve après la prise en main passé en
sécurité sous un pont une manœuvre
courante pour la navigation fluviale
moins facile qu'elle en a l'air nickel
au fil de l'eau et des heures les
manœuvres s'enchaînent tout ça dans un
cadre unique entre Sartrouville et
Montesson
idylique le coin est intéressant alors
tout comme sur un fleuve au final on va
avoir du courant on va avoir des vents
qui peuvent d'ailleurs tourbillonner
toute la journée donc on peut avoir un
vent qui vient d'une direction et qui
est très rapidement vient de l'autre
donc au final on arrive à bien
comprendre le principe du bateau c'est à
dire on est soumis au vent soumis au
courant des forces dominantes qui vont
agir sur nous et au final nous permettre
bien des très efficaces dans la
navigation par la suite c'est agréable
puis c'est surtout très pratique
parce que quand on habite la région il
faut bien pouvoir passer ça
sur un fleuve sur la sur n'importe quel
espace dont on dispose pour cette
formation compter entre 300 et 420 euros
il ne reste plus qu'à souhaiter bon vent
aux nouveaux bateliers